[GROWL]
[GROWLING]
SUIKA HARO: I'm Suika Haro.
I'm a game designer working
up the next games in Helsinki.
"The Walking Dead, Our World"
is a location-based game,
or when you open the game, you
see a map of your surroundings.
You're playing
everything on location,
and everything
happening the game
is actually tied to where
you are exactly in the world.
MARKUS MONTOLA: We wanted to
create a real-world game where
you literally experience
fighting and surviving
in your own city.
SUIKA HARO: Every one of the
players is in a shared reality.
So you can actually go and
play the game on the street
with your friend and see
the exact same things.
MARKUS MONTOLA:
Our entire game is
about streets and
cities and maps,
so Google Maps is an
essential platform for us.
With Google Maps, you can use
more and more real-world data
as a part of your
game, and that will
help you create the aesthetic of
blurring the line between game
and reality.
SUIKA HARO: The huge benefit
to using Google Maps for games
is simply that the data
that you get from the maps
is incredibly
consistent globally.
By liberating us from needing
to worry about the maps, what
Google has done has
allowed us to focus
on innovating the best
possible gameplay experiences
and the best possible social
elements into the games.
MARKUS MONTOLA: We managed
to avoid quite a bit of tech
trouble by being able to
trust that the map data is
consistent across
the world, especially
in the visuals where we can
use the building height data
and landmarks to make
the game feel more alive.
SUIKA HARO: "Walking Dead,
Our World" and Google Maps
is pretty much a perfect fit.
I don't think we've
ever been able to create
the game without Google Maps.
I'm really looking
forward to seeing
what other developers actually
do with location-based games
and the Google Maps platform.
The tools that we use
to create these games
are so much better now
that we can actually really
focus on the innovation.
I can't wait to play all
the games that developers
are creating with Google Maps.